la suite meilleur j'ai alors dit non
quelle est votre première réaction
il vaut mieux rire alors très surprise
tout d'abord je m'y attendais pas mais
très heureuse mon objectif est de
représenter tout d'abord la ligue contre
le cancer à travers l'île puis d'un
dîner videmment représente t elle
la miss martinique la martinique notre
part il amasse france
la différence alors fait n'est pas la
question le membre du jury et les
membres du jury sur les seules personnes
à pouvoir les complications
donc voilà oui j'ai des qualités très
ambitieux déterminé je vais toujours but
loin donc voilà après je ne sais pas
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire la
différence
alors les inscriptions se font sur
internet sur le site marc compromis
smartphone pardon donc après le premier
casting des castings après la
délibération finale pour sélectionner
les cinq finalistes
oui ma famille là très motivé à cela
après j'ai été poussé donc je me
présente et j'avais aussi envie de voir
si perez martin ont donc voilà oui quand
même